I want to share a podcast that I like
it's called the sum of all parts and the
description is that they share
extraordinary stories from the world of
numbers in simple terms they explain
instances where mathematics has an
influence on our everyday life it's by
the Australian Broadcasting Corporation
but I'm pretty sure that it's available
everywhere in one of the episodes they
talk about how the Australian netball
team studied the mathematics of
collective behavior and used this to get
an advantage over their rivals the
appearance of a collective brain and
animals is just the result of
individuals minding their nearest
neighbors and following a few rules such
as not getting too close these actions
add up to give majestic group behaviour
the netball team analyzed the dynamics
of the rivals to predict where they
would move another story talks about the
Mars probe that was lost when an
incorrect assumption was made that the
units being used were an imperial rather
than metric I'd really recommend this
podcast for anyone a little bit more
curious about numbers but I'd also
really like to know what the podcasts
are that you listen to so please leave a
comment